three two one this is Startalk Rio where
we bring the universe down to earth I'm
Neil deGrasse Tyson here with Colin
jokes Colin as always looking good thank
you uh we're in the cosmic queries part
of our time-travel show and you bring in
questions called from the cosmos that's
right right here into the studio mostly
from Earth so far so far uh and so we
left off with someone who wanted some
numerical yeah tell me that again one
they want you to fully solve a math
problem it was a basically a year to get
to a giant black hole you spent a year
orbiting it and then a year back to
earth so three years total
are you actually traveling backward in
time how much time has really elapsed
for the traveler okay so we're I'm sorry
how much try at a time is the last
Leonard fortunately we just came out of
a break
so before you fully solve this or is it
great to watch dust off my my relativity
equations and so here's the thing the
nearby black hole is is in the
constellation Cygnus and it was the very
first black hole ever discovered and
confirmed it's called Cygnus x1 and it's
called X because it comes from an x-ray
catalog of objects and we came to learn
that when a star is getting flayed by a
black hole the star that's in orbit
around the black hole that the
descending material can in its attempt
to spiral down the toilet bowl can be
heated to very extreme to extreme
temperatures so hot that it not only
radiates red hot and white-hot and blue
hot blue hot is the hottest among the
temperature of among the colors that you
can radiate it actually radiates an
x-rays you can do the calculation and
show that that's how hot the material is
and so the first x-ray telescopes in the
1960s and early 70s were essentially
discovering black holes in our midsts
they picked up something and they
discovered it was that mass yeah reading
so fast an ordinary star doesn't give us
x-rays of that level then you look
carefully in the stars orbiting
something you can't even see what's
there
there's
black hole Wow and is that is it speed
that's making it a building yeah exactly
so as the material spirals down it
speeds faster and faster and faster and
there's friction as it spirals down
friction with itself as it tries to get
into this tiny little hole and that
heats it up it heats it up ferociously
and you get lots of ultraviolet light
lots of x-rays and occasionally gamma
rays sing out if they could sell tickets
to watch that I was so doing yeah that
would be like an even better circus to
do to watch a star get flayed by a black
hole that's okay so a Cygnus x1 is six
thousand light-years away all right so a
beam of light if you watched it would
you have to wait six thousand years for
it to get there so you want to get there
in one year yeah okay well I'd love to
you want to get there in one year okay
so by your by your own time so we could
bring the equations of relativity if you
must know you're comparing two times the
time you on earth would measure versus
the time the person traveling experience
would would experience and in there
there is a factor of the square root of
1 minus V squared over C squared and V
Square is your velocity C squared is of
course the speed of light yes there it
is did I have to say it else no what was
wrong I wasn't thinking cookie all right
so what happens is the faster you go the
slower time ticks for you and so we're
going to slow down your time so much so
that only one year passes by meanwhile
6,000 years passes by for people on
earth that speed is 99.99999 86 percent
of the speed of light I was gonna guess
that
so that's damn near the speed of light
the point is you're going to speed
essentially the speed of light but not
quite but close enough so that we
watching you it'll take you 6,000 years
to get there you however your clock your
watch your metabolism your brain
thoughts the timer on your microwave
oven everything in your ship
has slowed down as far as we can tell
looking at you okay
and so so so they're experiencing you
think it's a year but we would say it's
6,000 years from here that's correct
your I think you're taking six thousand
years and you're just moving really slow
Wow
that's right so it's six thousand years
there so so if I'm someone who's
perennial II late and I'm trying to find
up time find new excuses for my employer
this might be one I might want to make
it will find you a black hole to do this
missus 6,000 years there then we just
add the year that you're in orbit around
the black hole 6,000 years back you
would have gone into our future by
twelve thousand and one years and you
would have aged only three years there
it is but everyone would have forgotten
about you so you people wouldn't even be
able to say oh you look so good because
they'd be like you you anyone who would
have said that would have been long
decomposed in the earth